monument leute die sache so und mein
outfit ist nicht ganz das ist hier nicht
ganz durch gedacht juti wanne
ihr kennt die beauty wanne wenn sie rosa
trägt klischees alle leute ist wiederum
ein fachmann bekommen zu einem neuen
test hallo leute ich es wieder mal
wandern willkommen zu einem neuen
adventskalender auspackt video von
zahnseide benutzen ich glaube ich ein
bisschen zu angriffs lieben es ist eine
stelle beim und ein bisschen
angeschwollen zahnseide benutzen kinder
zahnseide benutzen ist sehr wichtig und
jetzt gehts los mit dem hahn zu und
beauty adventskalender also mit den
amazon adventskalendern hat glaube ich
diese ganze leidenschaft hier erst
überhaupt angefangen ich bin mir nicht
sicher ob ich dieses jahr schon nach dem
kunstpreis adventskalender geguckt hat
jetzt den alkohol und ist der beauty
pressepreis einfach nicht lukrativ genug
gewesen also den gibt es nicht schade
aber ganz ehrlich ich sehe meine zukunft
eher in der beauty richtung wenn ihr
mein make-up heute betrachtet gorges
aber jetzt lass uns mal schauen was 2020
im amazon beauty adventskalender drin
ich habe mittlerweile so viel im juni
produkte dass ihr euch sicher sein
können dass es auch instagram
verlosungen end geben wird also falls
sie etwas gewinnen wollt müsst ihr mir
auf instagram folgen um es mit zu
bekommen wenn es dann so weit ist und ja
natürlich versuche ich auf diesem weg
ein bisschen mehr instagram verlor zu
kriegen was ist denn falsch damit
verklagt mich wie wir das rwi mal aus
das hat das geklappt als vermutet
die seien also diese rose goldenen
tannenbäume gefallen mir superb jedoch
zuerst dreinschauen
da dachte ich kann mich nicht erinnern
dass ich schon gesehen habe wieder drin
aussieht aber schießen vielleicht
endlich mal ein bisschen die sichtweise
dass ich mag auch eigentlich dieses
symmetrische aber moment ich versuche
mal was umzustellen das ist jetzt nicht
das schönste ist es doch ein skript oder
und soll dieser kalender nun wunderbar
präsentiert ich würde sagen wir fangen
jetzt an mit türchen nummer 1 also ich
bin begeistert vom design ich meine es
ist amazon wenn sie nicht schaffen einem
produkt designer zu finden der was
schönes kreierte hat jeff bezos bestimmt
was dazu gegeben damit sie sich einen
guten produktdesigner leisten konnten
die nummer eins dankeschön
in unserem ersten das ist das original
nein doch wie heißen der original
schwarm moment ich muss mal ganz kurz
überlegen
die blender oh mein gott warum ist der
beauty blender so gott verdammt teuer
kann mir das mal jemand sagen ich meine
der fühlt sich genauso an ihr
überschüssiges make-up wollte einfach
dass ihr erkennt dass ich mich mit
make-up auskenne und nicht auf dieses
video geklickt habe und dachte oh mein
gott sie will über make up reden also
jetzt ein bisschen fester als der
original wii blender aber gut auf amazon
kostet der fünf euro 69 und natürlich
rechnen wir zusammen ob wir unsere 60
euro für diesen adventskalender wieder
reinbekommen
2 positiv anzumerken ist hier in dieser
stelle dieser adventskalender besteht
komplett aus pappe nature boxee box
milde handcreme mit mandel duft schnell
einziehen drei von silikonen und para
bienen ich habe ein video von mailand
gesehen wo sie über silicon und so
gesprochen hat
einen sind sie gar nicht so schlimm ist
für einen selber das einzige was sie
machen ist die kanalisation verstopft
der filter von der kanalisation ich weiß
nicht irgendwas auf jeden fall so in der
richtung gewissen mit bahnen deshalb
ich werde jetzt nicht aufmachen sondern
verlosen denn ich habe schon viele
handcremes ich meine er ist es
wahrscheinlich selber man hat kauft sich
eine und dann reichlich für drei jahre
auch wenn man sie nur 12 monate benutzen
aber sind wir mal ehrlich wer hält sich
denn an diesen richtlinien so solltet
ihr auf jeden fall bitte nehmt euch ein
beispiel an mir eine packung handcreme
kostet ungefähr 4 eur 26 ich habe die
creme nicht bei amazon sondern im
einzelhandel erworben
dennoch muss ich sagen ich bin sehr
enttäuscht denn die creme wird unter dem
label nature box vertrieben
dies ist jedoch sehr enttäuschend die
inhaltsstoffe werden hier aufgelistet
das ist das erste mal dass ich sehe dass
ein produkt schreibt warum es da drin
ist aqua also wasser hilft die
inhaltsstoffe in der formel zu lösen
alkohol gibt geschmeidigkeit kuka
private sorgt für eine gleichmäßige
verteilung der formel auf der haut das
wirklich sehr natürlich angepriesen ob
das jetzt so 100 prozent dem
beschriebenen entspricht
wie schon komisch oder ich habe es
vergessen am anfang zu sagen leute
dieses videos nicht gespendet ist alle
diese news ist von st denn ich habe mir
den anwender selber gekauft ich habe
keinen kontakt zu amazon auch nicht zu
irgendwelchen anderen produkten das ist
wirklich nur frei meine meinung an
geschehen das kommt jetzt auf jeden fall
auf die verlosung seite es ist glaube
ich eine gute handcreme und wirkt
eigentlich alles natürlich im normalen
bereich
jetzt per 43 bei bbh fixierung brüste
lästige baby haare hiermit kann man sie
fixieren um mein gott ich wusste nicht
recht machen ja ich zog meine neffen dem
krad gekommen war und jetzt an mir bye
bye baby h
sabine mascara das baby habe ja und dann
ist es weg aber mir gefällt meine frisur
gerade absolut nicht so empfindlich ja
letztes gefühl nach dem zoff abziehen
oh oh mein gott das ist das was ich im
leben gebraucht haben ich mag ja das
muss auch einfach drin sein
ich muss sagen ich habe mein vom letzten
jahr so sind lippen beim und ich habe
meinen vom letzten jahr immer noch satte
dafür durfte ich habe vergessen das
ganze produkt einzutragen die vihear
hier eur 87 so gut wird es aber nicht
bewertet hier sterne von 103 hatte ich
muss sagen ich finde es gute und den 14
eur 94 was sind das für preise die
umsatzsteuer auf 16% deswegen sind das
alles so komische preise der kommt
natürlich in die verlosung denn ich habe
noch ein und warum einen neuen aufmachen
trainer martin hug world kostet dieser
hq und 20 millimeter für millimeter euro
60 japan natur die pure reparatur hqs
den zungenbrecher verwandelt ein
brüchiges strapaziertes haar an ein reh
generiertes kraftvolles wunder freut ihr
euch auch so sehr wie ich die nummer
sechs vielleicht gabor ist wirklich der
neue heiße scheiß oder geben euch jetzt
einfach mal hier einen 5 euro gutschein
doktor brief einzel us geht an die
zellen in der globus dabei face ampullen
verurteilt und darf stephen hawkings
kind im urlaub man kann den leuten echt
mit der angst vorm altwerden alles
verkaufen hätte
einem anderen adventskalender auch labor
und ich find's gut also die produkte von
babor sind gut aber ja das kommt auf die
verlosung seit 36 eur 95 für sieben am
col 36 95 jetzt sind wir wieder in der
mathematik durch sieben am polen sind
gleich fünf euro 27 also mal drei euro
also ist jetzt nicht das haben wir super
geile produkt aber sowas bringt mich
halt in weihnachtsstimmung kamin
knistert ist dann der bade kristalle
aktionsangebote hadamar das heißt du
bist in einem teuro 45 haben mich jetzt
nicht um aber naja nummer acht es war so
klar dass sie es wieder rein smeaton es
kommt auf jeden fall auf die verlosungs
seite nicht schlecht ist aber weil ich
es ist genau das gleiche schon hab also
das ist die amazon beauty marke die es
stabil die sich schlecht sie sogar
medienanalyse ich gerade was ist das ein
lipgloss oder her was kostet er billig
ist es nicht so die kombination wie wir
gesehen haben naja gut vier euro
62 wieso kirchen nummer ich bin
irgendwie nicht geflasht also außer
dieses baby hd sos for treatment und
beruhigt ekel sofort und vileda wieder
ins obere mittlere preisklasse oder eur
95 zahlt man dafür und ich werde sie
behalten denn ich hab nichts womit ich
einen pickel bearbeiten kann wenn einer
kommt zu sagen wenn die bewertung
es wirkt und ist auch nicht allzu
unangenehm auf der haut am anfang brennt
es ein wenig die pickel reifen dadurch
schneller und gehen etwas zurück
drei von fünf sternen sie sagt quasi das
produkt macht das was es verspricht gibt
drei sterne dafür
ihm hilft nicht bei allen hauttypen aber
für menschen mit mischhaut zu denen ich
auch ziele kann ich uneingeschränkt
weiterempfehlen
eine person hat eine leere box erhalten
ich denke mal wenn man eh nicht so eine
problematische haut hat und probleme mit
pickel dann glaube ich hilft es wenn man
eh sehr stark zu akne neigt dann hat sie
auch meistens was hormonelles zu tun und
dann hilft so eine creme auch nicht viel
ist ganz klein aber was mag wohl da drin
sein
wie schön ein braunes haar gummi ein
sehr kleines die nano rings brauche ich
aber tatsächlich gerade weil ich mir
immer flechten zipfel machen möchte und
nicht gummi dinger benutzen kann weil
sie nicht hier sind abkaufte diebes
nanoprodukten roma natürlich nummer 24
ist richtig sehe ich gerade noch ins
beauty instant love entwirren de sprühen
chor ohne ausspülen haben
also so das ist ein toller hacko da ich
jetzt aber viel zu kurze haare habe
werde ich sie natürlich verlosen
was kostet sie gut hierbei handelt es
sich um eine probe also zählen wir sie
mit null euro denn das wäre viel zu
günstig also ich glaube 5 cent oder so
oder zehn oder zwanzig sind aber sie
soll gut sein also die bewertungen die
ich hier auf amazon amazon hat das ding
fünf sternen also ist ein gutes teil
wird doch nur eine probe ist nummer 12
und wir sind in der halbzeit dieses mal
habe ich wirklich das bedürfnis viel
über die produkte zu reden ich hoffe
euch nervt das nicht okay was haben wir
hier for lashes bionic sehr um das ist
wirklich luxuriös einzige was mich jetzt
bei diesem sehr um interessiert ist ob
es wirkt denn ich selber benutze solche
serums nicht meine wimpern ich habe
schon lange wimpern durch meinen grünen
star und die augentropfen die jeden
abend nehmen muss haben nämlich zur
nebenwirkung dass meine wimpern voller
und länger werden aber in diese marke
das habe ich also das habe ich wirklich
noch nie gesehen wirkt für mich wieso
ein no name produkt oder für sich ich
beschäftige mich auch sehr wenig damit
vier milliliter es kostet 27 euro 86
also das ist ein toller gewinn
das wird auf jeden fall verlost keine
positive veränderung herbert hubert
herbert mensch nach vier wochen
verwendung hat sich bei mir gar nichts
getan
also es hält nicht was es verspricht
meine freundin nutzt ist als augenbrauen
sehr um meine freundin braucht mal
wieder nachschub und bat mich auf amazon
nach einem neuen wimpern jemand lässt
nun wird sie das serum lediglich für
ihre augenbrauen ich wollte es zwar
verloren aber ich werde
meine augenbrauen ausprobieren ich habe
echt ich will mir sinnvollere
augenbrauen haben es tut mir leid aber
stimmt man kann sie auch seine
augenbrauen verwenden
es ist halbzeit ich werde kurz was essen
gehen und wir sehen uns gleich wieder
ich habe in meinem bauch wie komme ich
was für eine überleitung mache ich jetzt
dass ich gerade suppe gegessen habe
super es gab suppe suppen subjektiv und
jetzt machen wir mal ein bisschen
schneller hier ja der nagellack den
roten nagellack von feind der marke von
amazon im verlose ich denn ich mache
jähnigen euro 99 für zwei flaschen ich
meine es ist rot das ist eine passende
farbe ist im winter nicht verkehrt 14
hat die gliss kur repair an tiflis
wunder versiegelung serum palo sich das
ist eine pflege hitze spray und alles in
eine und finde ich nicht bei amazon ist
so teil von so einer haar reihe gut was
kostet es ich kann mir vorstellen was es
jetzt kosten kann also irgendwie finde
ich das online nicht ja das einfach so
eine kur also ich glaube das kostet
irgendwie drei euro fünfzig ich meine
hier sind ja auch gute produkte drin
aber ich habe sehr oft den drogerie bei
also als ob man einmal so zu dm geht und
halt die basic produkte kauft und das
ist ja auch irgendwo in ordnung aber ich
hab mir hatte die wehr good morning
fresh skin gesichtsmaske bin jetzt nicht
der größte fan ich weiß nicht woher das
kommt ich glaube weil die inhaltsstoffe
sind bei nie wäre glaube ich jetzt nicht
so optimal wenn wir zwei euro inkl
der beauty okay was ist das produkt aus
anti brinkel serie mit nicht sehr gut
bewertet dreieinhalb sterne von 5 also
das habe ich auch diese augen falten ich
krieg das mal wenn ich make-up schlecht
auftrage wenn ich irgendwie falsche
produkte miteinander verbinden oder so
ist klar
also darf so schlecht bewertet ist würde
ich das jetzt nicht gerne verlosen weil
ich will euch nicht so ein schlechtes
produkt geben ich werde das tatsächlich
mal ausprobieren ob das irgendwie
wirklich die falten unter den augen vor
dem make-up irgendwie minimiert ich habe
jetzt aber noch nicht so viele falten
und 26 eur 95 also die bewertungen sind
wirklich nicht gut ich sage nur
einbildung ist auch eine bildung getönte
tagescreme ist genauso gut von wegen
zeiten verschwinden h das ist kein
bisschen zu sehen nicht mal mit viel
positiven denken da kann ich mein geld
auch in die mülltonne knallen
also bei 26 euro habe ich auch andere
vorstellungen gibt sie schon auseinander
gefahren scheiße ohne mineralöle labello
so habe ich noch nie gesehen ich als
teenager fand ich labello so cool
labello in seiner feder tasche zu haben
war wirklich toll support geil
das finde ich praktisch ich finde
nämlich will man so nur raus geht kurz
aus der tür und dann etwas getönte
lippenpflege drauf hat das ist ein
gewandter bello ist ja eigentlich eine
stabile marke er kostet 4 euro 73 es ist
schon ein preis in der 18
ich fühle mich wirklich mit einer
drogerie der neutrogena
hydro boost leichte formel für normale
und mischhaut trilogie komplex ich fasse
es nicht an wenn ich will's verlosen
nämlich viele cremes bei solchen
produkten bin ich wirklich auf diese
bewertung gespannt ja gut viereinhalb
sterne vom 5 das sind 89 eur 69 kostet
sie sonst ihr eine bewertung das gehen
hat mich einfach umgehauen ich habe bei
meinen ganzen kosmetik nach einer woche
in sorgt und habe mir das ganze
sortiment gekauft weil ich richtig
begeistert waren haut war superschön und
weich allerdings hat das nach zwei
wochen aufgehört ich habe eine extrem
trockene haut habe ständig das bedürfnis
mich einzucremen anfängliche absolute
begeisterung zur totalen enttäuschung
ich habe wirklich gedacht das ist
wirklich der knaller war es leider nicht
da wären klein aber das heißt ja nichts
kann ja viel hinter stecken ampullen die
habe ich noch von meinem letzten
kalenderjahr 10 euro ich meine die sind
bestimmt gut ich hab sie aber einfach
nie verwendet ja vielleicht wird sich
jemand darüber bei einer verlosung
freuen und viereinhalb sterne das heißt
dass produkten nicht verkehrt wie sie
bobic bange
ich weiß jetzt nicht wie sehr ich in
meinem leben diese spannung brauchen wir
mal in der haare hinten
die haben sich um 3 eur 70 und
dreieinhalb sterne von fünf sind halten
sie gut aber ich finde den look von so
einer plastik spange mit es nicht so
gezaubert die nummer 21 village los in
der farbe 114 was ist da steht zur
lipgloss etwas wirkt als ob so ein
matter nicht los wäre
drei sterne hat aber auch nur zwei
wertungen also der soll anscheinend nach
fünf minuten wieder verschwinden also
für 12 eur 62 ist jetzt nicht so gut
bewertet
ich habe auch diese marke noch nie so
wirklich gesehen doch das schönste
einfach an seinem kalender immer die
küchen zu suchen safe browsing water
face misst aqua dome brown sandte das
machte mein gesicht braun hast du das
point danach das ist nicht sofort braun
sondern transparent und das sieht mir
von der größe jetzt auch er
das ist eine probe was sagen die
bewertungen hinterlässt flecken und
schuppige haut bester selbstbräuner er
war
durchmischt türchen nummer 23 der vor
links jetzt bin ich entspannt sanfte
feste gesichtsreinigung mit rosen
großmutter reinigt sanft für alle
hauttypen eine gesichtsreinigung seife
fest und somit weniger verpackung und
viel produkt tatsächlich wenn man es
fest anstatt flüssigkeit hat man ein
bisschen länger was davon sechs euro 64
seubert mein gesicht großkinos sehr gut
verträglich schaum angenehm minimal und
nicht ins auge laufend man kann
eigentlich nie ein produkt helfen was
verpackungsmüll und sowas minimieren
der große moment das ist weihnachten und
dieses riesenpaket was mich die ganze
zeit schon an lächelt möchte geöffnet
werden
in türen nummer 24 findet sich
j
ich habe mir gerade neue saison geholt
remington on the go also perfekt für
2020 denn wir wissen das ist das jahr wo
wir reisen
ich weiß nicht was ist und was ist jetzt
die besonderheit warum heißt the go
ich vermute dass ich's verlosen werde
weil ich tatsächlich ja gerade ein neues
glätteisen gesorgt habe ist das klein
deshalb die kurze haare ist sehr gut
also hier steht optimum temperature
setting auf 200 grad ich glaube nicht
dass 200 gerade unbedingt nötig sind 23
euro und 110 also wenn ihr eine schnelle
art sucht eure haare ein bisschen zu
verbrennen mit 200 grad
dann habt ihr hier eure produkt gefunden
ja hat sagt man jetzt zu
preisleistungsverhältnis das preis
leistungsverhältnis ist in ordnung wohin
wollen wir dass er vom schnitt hier also
preis leistungs verhältnis ist absolut
krassny man bekommt über 200 euro für
seine 60 euro natürlich das ist ob die
produkt haben sich zu dem zeitpunkt
halten nicht so wirklich begeistert
jetzt wo ich im schnitt gemerkt dass es
über 200 euro geworden sind natürlich
das ist ob das ist jetzt aber für seine
marken wie amazon nicht so schwer weil
sie machen natürlich auch irgendwelche
deals mit irgendwelchen marken es gibt
eine breite menge an produkten aber
außer einem neuen absoluten favoriten
dem baby hamas karla kämmer
hinter gute basic produkte haut mich
irgendwie nicht vom hocker die diesem
niveau die dame so hoch gelegt werden
und der so macht so fühlt sich die
adventskalender an das ist irgendwie
nicht schlecht und ich will ihnen jetzt
nicht helfen aber jetzt ist auch nicht
besonders cool und gut es ging es ist
halt so
ja okay ich hab was für meinen preis
bekommen am ende muss ich sagen mit
eigenen adventskalender mal mache wenn
der mal kommt rechnete auch nicht so der
berner aber bei einem haken wie amazon
hat man also schreibt mir gerne mal in
die kommentare was ihr von diesem
adventskalender haltet und wie schreibt
mir gerne mal in die kommentare was ihr
von diesem adventskalender haltet und
wie gesagt wenn ihr eines der tollen
produkte gewinnen wollt dann folgt noch
instagram demnächst fangen die
verlosungen an ich muss das mal so ein
bisschen organisieren und dann sehen uns
beim video wieder ich hoffe ich jetzt
gefallen ich hoffe euch jetzt gut ihr
seid gesund glücklich es dann eure
beauty bahne
[Musik]